- When you see regret in a man's
eyes, it's fucking painful.
(gentle music)
You should really go to
a retirement home one day
and volunteer and just talk to them.
It will make you want to do
shit every minute of your life,
because when you're 90,
and you're not mobile,
and you're tired, and it's
over, you can't do it.
You can't do it.
You can't build that company you wanted,
you can't spend that time with your kid.
It's regret.
- Yeah.
- And it fucking drives
the shit out of me.
How old are you?
- I'm 27, 27.
- You got fucking time.
It's a balance of regret and patience.
Like you can go hard for three years,
do nothing right, wake
up, and be young as fuck.
The amount of people who
are watching this right now,
maybe even in this room,
that are sad, men and women,
that they didn't go for it,
and didn't make the move,
and didn't try, that regret
is a hell of a lot longer
and more painful, and more drawn out
than the instant
rejection of going for it.
It's just the way it is.
Even if you think of random, dumb stuff
like not asking out that
person in high school,
the stuff lingers.
It's the stuff that you
don't do that bothers you,
and so for the purebred
entrepreneurs in here
that haven't decided to make that leap
or take that at-bat, I implore
you to do so right away
because this window closes, too.
And the one thing that I ask you to do
is to not look back and regret
that you wavered on the moment
that was available to you.
I think your biggest
concern as you get older
is you wanna make sure you're
doing things for yourself,
not to make him proud,
and that's gonna be the
toughest thing for you.
The biggest poison in us is regret.
Everybody here is already sitting
with two, three, four things they can
think of very quickly that they regret.
Right now, already, you
got a lot more life to go,
and right now you feel okay because
you've got a lot of life to go.
But if you spend time with
people in their 80s and 90s,
the thing they will absolutely
teach you if you really dig
is regret fucking sucks.
Go talk to 90-year-olds.
They regret.
They talk about regret.
I wish is the opening line.
Go and volunteer in a nursing home,
because you're gonna see something
that you haven't seen
in such a pure state.
You will face regret in a way
that will fuck with you so hard
that you will stay focused and on track
for the rest of your fucking life.
The number one thing that you will taste
if you go to a nursing home
is you will find multiple people
that will talk to you about regrets
in a way that will pierce your soul
in a way that you've never felt before,
because they're actually in that place
where time has run out.
I just really think, I really believe
this from the bottom of my heart,
I think we only live one time.
And we don't act like it.
I just really wish people
knew that they were gonna die.
(audience laughs)
How can you not stay motivated?
Do you know that the odds of becoming
a human being are 400 trillion to one?
You gonna remember this?
(audience member coughs)
- [Woman] I do.
- Good.
One fucking life.